crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast i'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta
ask me cause you could trust that every
tuesday you already know
though orion sickler suckerstar juco
ground cool goes better than most jay
larsen
self diagnosed go down low this week
last week
here we go again [ __ ] the crab feast
yeah yeah welcome back to the crab
feast y'all know whoa
love the crap oh that ass
it's good to see you jaylards again hey
but i got the woo got the rick flares up
here didn't know you were here that's
good
it's so easy to get it what's with this
guy
uh ladies and gentlemen jay larsen over
here on the twos
great to be here with you jlarson
comedy.com jaylar comedy on facebook
twitter instagram and pinterest
uh i have not instagram storied yet have
you no no i haven't i don't know if i'm
going to
still debating guys let me know if you
want maybe we'll start using some of
that when we go out on the road and
stuff like that
are we going right that is a great idea
speaking of going on the road where are
we going to be sick
well first we're going to start the los
angeles california at la podfest
september 24th live craft feast podcast
from seven and nine
we're also on some other shows there uh
for the live stream that will be in
every room
every podcast archived on the website
for 30 days
the price for the entire weekend is 25
bucks but
if you use our code and get that j
larson discount y'all it's five dollars
off go to lapodfest.com to purchase the
live stream enter our promo code crab
feast
for the discount uh after that in
october on the 18th
san francisco punchline on the 19th of
october sacramento punch line
where are we going to be in the 21st
circle we're going to be in chicago for
two shows chicago
two shows both on the 21st 22nd we're
shooting on down to st
louis again buy your tickets there at
the club if you want to avoid some
service charges
then where are we headed we're going to
asheville on november
5th we'll be in asheville north carolina
off to
the great city of boston great city on
november 6th at laugh boston november
8th we will be
caroline's new york caroline's new york
november 9th
helium in philadelphia november 10th
drafthouse comedy in washington d.c 11
11 baltimore charm city
will be there these are all one-nighters
go get them now now get your tickets now
uh they are going quick
in all cities actually which is a
testament to you guys thank you very
much there are all shows are available
on rhinecicle.com the craftheast.com
the merch store is back you guys are
snagging it up we're gonna have some new
stuff up very very soon for you a new
shirt
um we'll be out on the road too with the
tour poster we'll be selling out there
um and thank you for always using the
amazon link and help keeping this show
free the premium apps they're cheap but
they make a difference for us
on the facebook fan page if you're not
following already go over there hit that
up so you can
keep up with tour info and merch and all
that good stuff and uh always love
reading the itunes page reviews
and um you guys are the best fans of the
podcast
proud to have you and we're proud the
way you represent us out there as fans
of comedy and podcasting
we always how often do we say you so and
so said you went and saw him at a show
and you love blah blah blah come see us
you guys been asking for us to come for
so long we're coming come see us
and do us a favor grab some friends and
say hey it's gonna be
it's it's not we're not doing a live
stand uh
podcast we're doing live stand-up so if
your friends like to laugh and
feel good then they should come and then
hopefully they'll be fans of the crab
fees that's how it all works and uh
we're looking forward to seeing you guys
and we're looking forward to this next
guest back third time four pipe four
peter four peter i'm pretty sure he's a
four percent i forgot the second it
wasn't that great yeah
um ladies and gentlemen we are proud to
have
back actually we really need to fill in
a hole someone canceled but we can't
wait to have him back for his third
appearance on the craft feast please
welcome
mr daniel vicker what are you gonna
drive here welcome back to the crab face
instinctively when did you know you keep
going with the clap i i thought it the
whole time i'm like i'm just going to
keep going today i just felt that
i felt like you guys were going to
that's what's good about having the bbk
because he's got so much
improv chops he gives off vibes and we
just all picked all in on it
it's actually your fourth though is this
not your fourth yes
this is four well we're gonna pull that
old one remember that one that wasn't so
great the second the second one yeah
you got it everybody
john logan you guys asked for us to pull
it we're gonna pull it yep
john logan's gonna do the second one hey
can i tell you guys something i thought
of
uh i should have said this to you off
air so you could shoot it down shoot it
out on air
i was like man the crab feast fans are
some of the best fans in podcasting no
they're
the okay well i know you have to you
would but
right sickle but i what if you guys
started doing a thing where when you had
guests on
you said who do you want to give a shout
out to and they just pick maybe some
friend of theirs from
that they grew up with that's on twitter
or a co-worker or somebody that they're
on a show with if they're on tv or
whatever and then crafty
and they're like what why are 300 people
saying hey hey foot player
to me or whatever all right then who do
you like this is a brand new
brand new born right here on this
episode
because the best like then can you
imagine all the people sitting there
like let me hit this gary saying this
guy's like 363 followers it's like
what is happening and going through and
like finding some dirt on being like yo
man love that pie you made two weeks ago
that's a great idea all right
so feasters you now have free range
yeah carte blanche hey hey player yeah
our people don't harass anybody they
don't give them a hard time it's the
nicest tournament it's the best
imagine if you could do this at a bar
and you just had everyone in the bar at
one point come up to your friend and be
like how you doing man
you'd be like what the [ __ ] is happening
yeah all right so who's the first person
right here this is this is the oh my god
this far ahead
why don't we no one from mancation
this is the maiden voyage right yeah let
me okay i'm gonna put we'll make sure
that
it because i wanna give it to somebody i
don't wanna what if i say their twitter
wrong
oh man this is gonna be worth it okay
i'm gonna go with one of them
really i mean no it's gonna be worth it
for me i don't know if it's worth it for
you guys we're just keep filling time
anyway right
it's gonna be okay would you believe my
phone's locked
all right it's bradford wilson that's
right
yeah that's who i wanna go with what's
his twitter i'm gonna give it to you
it's bradford
he goes by bradford doesn't go by brad
anymore no i mean some people call him
brad but his name is bradford
are all brad's bradford no some are
bradley
or just a straight up brad braderick
i've never heard of bradford
okay here it is bradford
j j a y dub d u b
b r a d f o r d
j a y d u b give him a shout out you
know what's [ __ ] crazy is he's right
no bradford
oh it's so good to have you back
fantastic idea unfortunately
well look you know you're you're uh what
is it a quad
uh pete here right now yeah so uh
we have four of the six legs you sure do
for the stars yeah uh we have an update
that we don't always get the second one
you know
we don't always get up so
you made a return trip to the original
marshall fields now called bases do you
want to do your plugs
oh yeah you should do your i wanted to
see how far we could get
uh follow me daniel van kirk at daniel
van kirk on twitter instagram my myspace
is still out there
and then what else i've got a show
coming up
on the 20th of september
it's low visibility that is a two-man
sketch show written and performed by me
and kenny stevenson kenny stevenson and
me
and that's at ucb at 9 30 p.m
on the 20th and then on the 22nd i'm
doing the please advise show at the
improv
and then on the 23rd i'm co-hosting
tony sam's character show what else do
you want guys follow scarborough county
they got you in that 9 30 slot huh yeah
uh
hindsight which you've been on and you
are you are so good in it
fantastic and then i'd love to come back
and do it again i got plenty of pictures
i i just do have something i just had
somebody on guess i just had somebody on
uh guests for the second time and it is
great because every
it's just each picture why do you have
so many pictures who's the big photog in
your family
my dad took a bunch of them but then
they all ended up so throughout all the
years of moving like i lost
good we had good [ __ ] you know what kit
as kids we were like
like brooks robinson rookie cards like
all that [ __ ] ends up getting lost yeah
okay we had autograph baseballs from jim
palmer and eddie murray and
you move and you move and you move and
you move and we also think our mother
might have sold some [ __ ]
yard sale we're not even gonna lie we
thought that for a while a quarter
uh but you'd end up finding like you
know just
over the years i guess people would be
at my grandma's they'd all just put them
somewhere and she collected them and
then i ended up just getting a zip lock
of
all these random old pictures so yeah
you have a lot of great
you know every time uh we're currently
pitching hindsight around to possibly be
a show in
some great capacity or another and i
always bring up your episode when i'm
pitching it thanks man uh
producer jay hopefully you'll come on
sometime yeah but uh
you're i always say because people like
what do people bring when they bring
photos because people don't know
uh my comedians come on they bring three
photos from any chapter of their life
then we talk about the context of their
life when that photo was taken
it drops on thursdays for throwback
thursday people listen to show and be
like i gotta see this photo or vice
versa they see a photo i have to hear
what happens
and people always say what are people
wrong i'm like people bring everything
andy peters
brought a picture of him grabbing a
girl's boob by licking her face that
woman ended up being his wife
sickler brought a picture because he
like cheated on a math test
promised his teacher he would do his
homework that night the teacher didn't
believe him went to his house
you were gone you lied to your teacher
to prove it your brother took a picture
of your dad and the teacher ended up
being the last photo of your dad
so i always that's amazing well why'd
you waste it on his podcast
i've told that right what happened was
my brother and i
had the same math class and we always
had different classes
always had different classes but just
because but this one math class we both
were in
and uh unbeknownst to me and unbeknownst
to him we both failed the [ __ ] out of
that test and we had to take it home
because you failed and get it signed by
your parents so
we had to have dad autograph the [ __ ]
thing well
i didn't know he failed and he didn't
know i failed so i just said [ __ ] it and
i signed my dad's name on it
and we took it to school i turned it in
and then like a day or two later the
teacher gets up in front of everybody
he's like
where are the sickler brothers sickler
brothers and he's got these two papers
in his hands he's like well you both
failed the test last week and i knew
right away i looked at him and he looked
at me we both were given that look like
you
[ __ ] idiot he said i asked you to
take it home to your dad and get it
signed
and you guys did you did but your dad
has two different signatures he holds
him up in front of the whole [ __ ]
class
and he's clouded as hard and he goes now
that would be the best part about being
a teacher
yeah dude's name was mr mangle and he
goes and he was old school he was the
one playing
the jets right yep definitely nick's
next buddy
he uh he wore the tie and he had the
protractor and
he had a sign curve uh that uh
on his wall at home like this dude was
hardcore nerd math you know very and
loved it very into it embraced it and
he's like now
friday night is pete's night at the mang
hold house i am going
to pap happ's i'm gonna get the two
pepperoni special
and then i'm gonna swing by your house
on the way home
uh and make sure that your dad knows
about this and we're dying we're like go
ahead
please come by look there's no way he's
going to [ __ ] be right you know he's
got a van
his family we're like there's no [ __ ]
way
so did he tell you you had to be there
then no he didn't
he just said he was going to do this and
no one was buying it we weren't buying
it knowing the class
like we're all laughing he's smiling but
is anyone buying that two pizza special
like everybody i bought that everyone
got special right pap's on a friday
night
so have you ever worked in a pizza place
are you kidding me
christ we're still this is still on his
plot it's the longest plug ever
no keep going you don't care
so um remember i am a twin so
i'm 16 at the time and it's my weekend
to have the car
because i had to split a car with my
brother every other weekend that weekend
and that divorce really took
me happiness we had to share a car
my dad wasn't buying two [ __ ] cars
and by the way it was a goddamn station
wagon
you know the 1977 dodge ashman limited
edition was a wood panel
so i'm out i don't give a [ __ ] as soon
as i get home i got the keys i am my
homework stuff did you even think about
him actually coming back
to you after we left the class i didn't
even [ __ ] i forgot about it
just laugh we're all laughing on and
moved on about my life was he a cool guy
like he would joke around like this a
lot
yeah okay so i go out for the night or
whatever and i'm back by midnight when i
gotta be in
and uh my brother comes up to me he's
like mr mangle stopped
invited i'm like [ __ ] he's like yes
he did he definitely stopped by i'm like
there's no way my dad's like he stopped
by and showed me the test you two are
idiots my dad's laughing you know
so um and then my dad dies
like a few days later no yeah a few days
maybe a week or so it wasn't much it was
may tops maybe two weeks it was like
right at that time of the year
and then you know back then it wasn't we
didn't have a polaroid we took a picture
well and your dad was a heart attack but
that was hard to tell so do you think
part of the stress of you guys cheating
on these things
i had to do it absolutely
absolutely so
after he dies we get the film developed
and
there's the [ __ ] picture of my dad
and mr mangled shaking hands at our
front door and they're both
he's got i brought on his pocket they're
both laughing
and that ends up being because we
cheated on that [ __ ] hand
and i went out that's right because it
had to be proven
since i wasn't there to see it the last
photo of my father taking was that
picture
on all that had to happen for that
picture to be taken yeah
pizza night and he even he even asked
when we went back to school
um he said i got to ask you guys was
that the last or one of the last
pictures of your dad
we were like that was the last picture
of our father ever so yeah he's in that
hold on a sec
so your brother took it yup whose idea
was it was your dad's idea or your
brother
whose idea to take that picture i want
to know it's probably my dad and my
brother because they were like
or it might have been mr mango because
he's like there's no way ryan's ever
gonna believe i
actually came by tonight family's out in
the van in the driveway
it was just a quiz you know what i mean
it wasn't like it was a [ __ ] midterm
or something it was just like one of the
weekly tests and we both bombed it
but the dude rolled by so yeah but what
i loved about your
uh show was you were surprised you were
like you're not even in these [ __ ]
pictures and i was like oh i just
thought you did you never said i had to
be
you know you just said photos from it
yeah so i feel like i was one of the
only people or early people to bring
pictures that i wasn't even in but they
were it was my
1990 honda civic with the original rims
parked in the playboy mansion yeah
stories of the people that you lived by
at that time um and then i brought the
elf
you were in that one i had to be gary
coleman's stunt double when i was the
elf that played the sweepstakes
and then the big time the last picture
of my father ever taken
i brought good [ __ ] yeah dude i brought
quality [ __ ] well i'm definitely going
to have you back and then jay we'll
we'll work it out yeah please he don't
even have pictures he's gonna have to
i honestly don't what are you talking
about i don't the only pictures in my
mine are all home my mom's got photo
albums [ __ ] like well that's what i
gotta get
i know but like my family still exists
ryze is gone
social media so that's why he got him
there's people still involved in mine
you know what i mean people
are still taking pictures they still
have their pictures they like to hold on
to them the
people say this [ __ ] they're only photos
and i'm like that social media has been
around for 10 years
so you at least have two or three
chapters of your life already i'll be
like this is when i was just starting
out doing [ __ ]
you post old sets on instagram god knows
why
but yeah i've seen you post old sets and
yeah that's my comment chapter of your
life
now i was still crushing then it's not
like i wasn't i think you'd take any
opportunity to talk about that
shitty house you lived in that nobody
was zoned for
remember that when he's when he was home
schooled yeah he was squatting on a
[ __ ] thing you know
condemned house all the time yeah yeah
it's another opportunity for you to talk
about that house
it's a great stage in my life you know
what i mean it's funny you live in a
condemned house now why don't we talk a
little bit about that
uh it's more of a box but it's mine but
it is yours don't play with my keys
you know what who has a flash drive on
their keys you know
i have everything i need right here
all right let's hear it probably i want
to go back to because you're probably
imagining your marshall field days you
probably carried a bunch of keys like
that it's just it's ingrained in yeah
welcome to the segway get into more of
that after the break
trying to be professional here and keep
this [ __ ] rolling while you guys shake
keys over there
dude uh come on so everyone there's not
a
feaster who ha and if you haven't heard
his last episode go back and listen
to it it's literally his by the way all
his plugs are in there
we didn't really need to plug i did the
show in houston they said
i just did this in flappers or uh ice
house too
they said what do you want your credits
to be and i'm like could you just say
three-time member three-time guest of
the graduate and you can see him next
season on bob's burgers
that's a lot we're hearing next season
on bob's burgers yeah i always do it all
i did in madison too and people were
like what what what are we doing
what yeah bob's burgers i know but
what's the crap no they don't the other
it's the other way
uh so marshall fields is now macy's yes
and
the store is still entirely in a return
i did i went back to check out the
things that were there
just to see how everything's holding up
yeah walnut still doing your rounds huh
i did i did i went to did you walk
harold i went to
treasure old stuff yes i went to that
fifth floor children's department
bathroom it's still the children's
department and the bathroom door is
right there any snatching grabs going on
down there
i went down to the pedway i took all
these it's on my instagram and i sent
them all to you yeah you sent them to me
i took pictures of the atrium where
dudes would meet up with each other to
see if they wanted to go get down in one
of the bathrooms
it it it was a bit of a i don't know if
you guys have places like that i was
busting your balls about the pizza place
but
that you worked at but if it's still
around if you've ever gone back to one
of those
like clearly defined life job chapters
if
just you never heard the story when i
went back to my grandfather's bakery
13 years after he owned it three
bakeries since he owned it and they
closed two months after i went visit it
and they had my grandfather's original
sign waiting
for a member of the family to come pick
no yeah really
i might have helped kill my dad jay shut
that [ __ ] bakery down
open for decades he shows up 60 days
later but yeah
that's what i usually do like the smell
i was having so much like sense memory
so for the yeah for the feasters
and you guys both responded to it and
then i thought people would get a kick
out of it
it's all still there new codes dude
there was things i couldn't remember
there was another food court
up by the five-star restaurant that i
had completely forgot i know it's
riveting
second food it was like uh i forgot
there's like a museum area the place all
in there
yeah all in that means we're going to
chicago in october right yeah we are
um go please go i mean it's one of the
first things we had on our list we said
we might try and catch a bears game and
then it was
marshall fields it was like one of the
two things what day are you there
october
13th marshall fields forever
i think it's the 20th time you've got to
look at the gotta look at the dates go
to craft feed
craft feast.com with shows click the
show's link it's all right
there really quick good lord you've been
in chicago we're at the high hat in
chicago oh nice
that's great i'm sorry to promote your
[ __ ] show jeff yeah i know i know
you're doing a great job
uh so yeah i went back and checked it
out and i saw and i kept waiting to get
like i was looking to see if there were
people following me around pretending to
be shopping but
nobody picked up at 109.99 nobody cares
about it
10.98 1097. i think they'd be a little
bit more on top of what are you keeping
it happening
over there yeah 10.99 yeah i bought two
pairs of shoes i fit right into the 10
10. do you remember what a 1099 is
i'm not sure the white guy the white guy
oh yeah and then 1098's black and 1097's
hispanic hispanic and then 1096 was
other asian or uh
and then everything that's my hope too
is i want to find somebody who still has
the card with all the codes
because i need that i need that that
would be tight yeah well thanks for
having me on
yeah man this has been great man thanks
for sharing another marshall field story
it's great
um i want to hear about this story of
your sunglasses
oh getting stolen yeah okay so
i don't do you guys don't have big heads
you have normal size
i mean i thought i did and then i ran
into a dude with a giant head and you're
like whoa
and it's like a big head yeah yeah well
so i had these sunglasses that were
expensive i was in like a sunglass hut
putting them on trying on every single
one fine with work they're
versace and then i got them as a gift
and i was like i didn't spend any money
on these i ended up losing those
so i said i'm gonna buy myself a pair
technically i've had two pairs in my
life for the cost of one
so i bought them i had them i'm at a
shoe store
and i'm sitting down and i you know you
kind of have your personal stuff like in
your
your area i'm on one of those little
shoe benches and they're just
far enough away from me to where they're
obviously mine but they're not right
next to me
and then i had to check in for a flight
and i'm checking in for flight and as i
do i notice a guy
just a little too close to the bench
walk by and i look up and i'm like is
this a big shoe store a small shoe store
a shoe section in a big store warehouse
shoe
sales the place big spot yeah and i look
up
and the guy walks by and i go don't be
so suspicious
you said that to him myself oh cause i'm
like i don't
i'm back to your marshall fields days
yeah yeah it's in you man people he's
walking around
so i check on my flight and then i get
an important email and i'm running back
to the email
and i do my thing and i kind of feel the
guy walk by again and i'm like
let it go or people are just people
so why should it be i look up gone
sunglasses are gone now i'm freaking out
10.97
1098.
it's the real part of the reason why i
didn't want to be of course i was like
don't be
racist it's just a guy man
profile right yeah and so then when they
got stolen part of me too was like
[ __ ] don't why i didn't
i wish you wouldn't have stolen because
i told myself to not be suspicious
because it made me feel racist
and so then i go over and i'm like
somebody just stole my sunglasses
and they're like oh where is he i'm like
he's not walking around the store
wearing them yeah he's right over there
over there about a night go ask him to
give him off
he's gonna take him off and give him
back to me so then
they're like oh well i go can you pull
the tape because i need pull now he's
pulling tape
guys we pulled chain on camera 12. i did
start to go back in
oh it gets worse so i go could we pull
the tape
and this guy is just a glorified bag
checker you know what the yeah
you got to check your bag and uh i just
have a highlighter he's like i don't
know if we do
i don't think it's on tape and i'm like
pull tape means
i want to see i need to know that this
is the guy who stole it and he was like
i mean i can get the manager on the
phone so then he calls the manager and i
go hey
look somebody just stole my sunglasses
in your place i needed to pull the tape
and he was like look i'm going to be
there in about an hour and a half i go
so you want me to wait here
and he's like this guy's on the loose
man i think he got two foot measures
he's uh he's over at the pretzel stand
come on oh we got a 1098 running through
the south side parking lot right now
so i go i go look this is where i tried
to be like i go
hey you know what i've done lost pet
loss prevention asset protection i
understand how it works so i need you to
come down here and pull the tape i got
to decide if i want to pull a place
where it goes
oh so you know how it works huh and i go
yeah i know how
can we not get in a pissing contest even
though i kind of was the one who started
it
and so he's like i'll be down there in
an hour and a half
i try to wait for like 10 minutes and
i'm i'm hot
he calls me later that night and he says
uh
yeah man i left you didn't wait for him
no he goes yeah man that guy took your
sunglasses
i go it's all on tv yeah he got you
i like it i'm like you don't have to
respect his game
i mean he walked by i wish he said why
didn't you look up that first time he
walked by
that's the only time i did look up jay
he goes that's what he said he's like
you know you can see him walk by and you
look at him
and then you just went right back to
your phone and he came back and took
those sunglasses that must have been an
important email
yeah i know i was like all right i must
have got enough for
me i go
all right so flash forward like
a week week and a half later
i'm walking down the street uh
at in downtown and i see a a woman
sitting in front of starbucks and she's
like uh not
uh you know there's like there's
homeless sad
then there's almost like homeless proud
oh where they're like
this is where i live yeah i don't want
to live with you [ __ ] right
and then there's homeless uh drugs
and then there's like homeless disabled
down on their luck right
there's a great comic i can't remember
his name he had a joke because i have a
hard time
feeling bad for some homeless people
when i know all they need to do is just
call their dad and say i'm sorry
that is a level of homeless people yeah
so the
this was drug she was drugs and uh
she's like okay help me out tell me come
on just help me out you know and then
there's a guy
like a big guy with a shirt that doesn't
fit very well with two dogs
and he's like get out of here get out of
here like at
his t-shirt you know and like chino
shorts and
deck shoes i know him well and so he
goes you get out of here stop asking
people for stuff
and then he's in the middle of the
sidewalk she's to his left to the right
is this black dude and he's like uh he's
like
man stop yelling at her and then he's
like i can yell out if i want to and
he's like no you don't what do you work
here
you don't work here and i'm like work
here as for the city we're not
we're not in our place right so
how long after this is from the
sunglasses like a week we can have okay
and so it's fresh off yeah i'm still mad
yeah
i'm mad because right now the sun's
probably blinding you yeah yeah
and i'm faced with another deal do i buy
these perfect sunglasses again because
now i'm in i'm
i don't want to spend another too much
money on these yeah
they do fit great though i can't wear
ray bans it's a whole other thing so
i walk through and i figure this is
another downtown altercation
uh you see these all the time i i could
tell you another one that's horrible but
like not as bad as the last time when
that guy got raped on the lawn at
denny's but it's bad
it's really bad
so i just walk through i go another
downtown altercation
and i don't pay much money to it later
on that day i'm walking again
same street different direction about a
block and a half from where the
starbucks uh was
and i see the black guy and the
drug homeless girl and they're talking
to each other like aggressively talking
to each other and i'm walking up and
he's like
they're outside of the mexican
restaurant cusados
and he's like do you want me to get you
water and she goes yeah
and he's like i will get you water right
now she's like i want water
and you're like wow what animation are
you guys seeing that isn't happening
right now you know
he's like okay i'm getting you water and
she's like thanks
and i i'm walking by and i've got past
them as they're ending and he turns
to walk away so he's now slightly behind
me and walking away
towards gusadas to go get them water or
her water
and she stayed right where she was and
something tells me
just watch watch him walk into gusanos
i don't know why so i kind of stop she
doesn't know
anything exists let alone me she doesn't
care and he walks up to the door and
right by the door they have their
outdoor seating
he gets to the door he stops looks
around
bends down to the ground and under the
person's seat who's sitting right there
by the door eating with a couple of
other people
is a wallet and he picks up the wallet
and he puts it in he just turns around
doesn't even care about her water
anymore
he did stiffed on the water yeah hey
i said water i bought you champagne
right
and he goes and he just turns on and
starts taking a beeline and i just go
no uh-uh no not in front of you i yell
it out
you're a vet in my head i'm like another
scenario
where something's set down in somebody's
personal space another 1098
doing it again not this time that didn't
matter
you [ __ ]
so not two ten ninety-eights in a week
you suddenly i start walking up behind
him
and i said no before i go no but he
doesn't hear me
and i start walking up and now i'm
thinking to myself how do i wanna handle
this
because he he he doesn't know anyone
knows he just took this wallet
and i walk up behind him and i think to
myself if i stop him we're going to get
in a fight
if i yell at him i could end up having
to chase him
and and get sharon water you're not
you're going to be the water boy
hey so she's still standing there she's
the one that attacks you when you're in
the fight with him right i mean you
don't see it
and if he has a weapon or anything on
him like why give the opportunity to
escalate it
so of course the 1098 would have a
weapon that's right
you said that you sent all those pizzas
in comedy you can use
uh sunglasses as a weapon if you need to
yeah well not me because i didn't have
it that's right but the other 1098 did
so i walk up and i i double hook both of
his arms
[ __ ]
have you ever noticed how many jackets
on this person
i would have just approached and been
like hey man you're caught on now he's
going to run and then you're going to
chase him whatever yeah i would have
just
yeah would have kicked his feet knocked
him down oh now he's taking phoenix
casual approach that's it
first he's he's double [ __ ] hook
headlock
i double hooked him and i go no and he's
like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
and literally he was wearing like three
jackets and they're all like flailing
around while i'm trying to hold on to
him
and then he goes to like turn around on
me and then i just
hip him and drop him right down on and
as i do
is there a crowd watching this there is
now yeah
as i do the wallet comes out and
opens like a like just like like
yes and money and everything just goes
everywhere
and if you much like throwing food to
birds in home
in downtown homeless area if you throw
money
it's all sudden there are just people
everywhere right and the money's all the
ground i hope he's like he's like that
was my wallet that was my wallet and i'm
like no it wasn't you're
we're starting this is where we're gonna
start from before we get to the truth is
that it's your wallet
yeah and he goes that was my wallet that
was my want and i go
it was not your wallet he's like i'm
sorry man i didn't mean to take your
wallet i'm sorry for taking your wallet
and now i've got to tell him it's not
even my wallet yeah
i'm just straight sidewalk renegade yes
yeah yeah and so
i've gotten i've got him down on the
ground and then security comes out
from the building like the residential
building that it's in and
i'm like hey i'm i'm not zoned for this
zone i'm saying they've got handcuffs
and it happened in their building that
they're also because guisados is in the
same building
so i go uh i go
yeah i go hey i was wearing the same
shoes that'll come into a second
and i go i go i'm holding him down and
he was like
i didn't mean to take it i didn't mean
to take it i'm like you you grabbed it
you got well i didn't know whose it was
i was gonna turn it in i go where where
were you going
and then people are like picking up the
money and then the security guard comes
out and he like cuffs the guy
is the guy who's wallet out yet he
hasn't even shown up yet that guy's in
the middle of a didn't even know he's
not eating some chips and walking there
he's waiting to get his [ __ ] bill and
then
figure out like my wallet so so he's
standing there and then they
there's a whole [ __ ] charade going on
right now
he just lives in some flamingo guitarist
no
the amount of money that came out of
this wall was easily three four hundred
dollars damn
i mean for some versace sunglasses guys
i'm big so and it's also a lot of like
foreign money like euros and stuff in
america like this this was the jackpot
for this guy if he had gotten to have
this wallet
they could have bought as much bonds
coming up he didn't even know
he didn't even know what he got double
eagle came fine
do you guys ever almost get roped into
buying that [ __ ] on tv no
no so uh i'm holding them down they come
in they cuff him and then i'm standing
there
and i i feel like i've done a really
good thing right
and i look down and my new air force
ones
shoes are just scuffed to hell oh wait
the ones you bought when your sunglasses
got stolen
these look nice yeah
they are scuffed and i'm like
[ __ ] i'm pissed
because now i'm like what i ruined i
ruined my own shoes
for nothing how much were those shoes 90
bucks and how much were the sunglasses
two months 180. so you're down 270.
right
right all of a sudden this guy comes out
and that dude's down 400.
oh no because all of a sudden he walks
up and he his name was like tack
or something like that he goes uh he's
like whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa this is my stuff this is
my stuff this is my stuff this is my
stuff this is my stuff
and he's people are like picking it all
up or whatever and he's like oh god
you took my wallet man and he was like
oh man i found a wallet
which probably legally speaking he did
he did
and so uh they're like holding down he's
like oh my god dude
thank you thank you so much he's like
collecting his stuff or whatever i'm
like
where have you been and he's like oh
we're just
sent over there and uh we saw this like
all this happened over here my
girlfriend said oh yes
somebody reached down behind your chair
a few minutes ago and i'm like
you need to have a talk with that person
she's not even giving you a heads up
when somebody's like under your chair
so then he goes uh he's like hey man
let me give you like twenty dollars and
i go this is all like in the heat of the
moment
like it's all still happening and i go
uh i go
no you somebody tried to take your money
i'm not gonna take your money
that's what i just prevented from
happening except for all these people
over here well
no except for when i looked down and i
was like these shoes are ruined though
and he's like oh man i can't believe i
got all my stuff back i'm like yeah it's
just
now i'm gonna spend the rest of my day
trying to clean these shoes and he's
like
and i'm thinking how many [ __ ] times
am i gonna have to drop
that i gotta get the shoes clean before
you say to me
how much would it cost to get your shoes
how many euros is it going to take yeah
exactly
and so then uh the dudes stand down
there and the guy goes
i guess we're calling the cops and the
security guard from the building goes oh
i already called him
and he's like oh i don't know if i want
to press charges i
can we just let him go before the cops
get here and i go no
no oh why not i'm like i mean one
i ruin my shoes for nothing
that's the first thing you want to take
care of your shoes maybe we can let them
go
i said to him i go the reason why you
have to get the cops here and if you
don't want to preservation if they
get here that's up to you that's fine
but if you don't
then all that happened was these shoes
never go on a police report right
that shit's good all that happened was
if the cops don't come all that happened
was is
i tackled a man on the sidewalk for no
reason
that he literally could call the cops on
me then and go
yeah man some 1099 just tackled by us
we're walking down the street so through
so then uh the guy goes i just don't
know how i press charges i'm like tac
listen to me
you can do whatever you want but the
cops four cop cars come by two of which
stop
to tell us they are not the cops that
are coming are you serious yeah i swear
to god
and then i i'll be honest about this
story there's a moment where the guy was
laying down on the sidewalk
and he starts trying to talk to tac
and he's like look man i saw the money
i just wanted to take it i i saw the
wallet i wanted you know i'm just trying
to
get some money i'm hungry can we just
let me go
don't press charges on me like just let
me go just let me go tax like let me
give this guy a couple bucks
okay man you need something you didn't
want the twine let me get you some shoes
and then meanwhile the homeless ladies
back there [ __ ] dying
so as he's talking to us the security
guard starts being like
shut up like yelling at the homeless guy
yeah
flexing on him yeah shut up don't turn
around keep your face in the ground and
i go
whoa he's just talking to him
there's no and you could this is my perp
this is my purp
but you can see in the moment where some
guys who get into like bouncing at bars
or being security guards or whatever
they're in it for
the for these moments and i just i had
to tell the guy i'm like
he's not going anywhere man he's just
and tax talking to him
it's nobody it's okay tax got this i
know his girl's a little slow to draw
but tax on top of this all right
so then so then i go i'll wait around
right around i got other stuff i have to
do
i was hoping to see you guys actually
because it was the
super serious like anniversary party
though i couldn't go yeah
yeah so i wanted to go to that with my
dirty ass shoes
and i i said that i go all right tac you
can do whatever you want i got to get
out of here
so then i i leave i end up walking
around i see tac
like an hour later and i go hey what
happened and he's like oh i just had him
let him go
and i'm like that's fine he's like i
want to thank you for all your help i'm
like
yeah it's just these shoes
i tried one more time oh yeah man keep
it though
whatever you didn't give a [ __ ] and they
i mean there's still a spot on
it's it's not good so yeah i just but in
that moment i was like
i want somebody to do for him what no
one did for me and stop this
to be honest too i would have let the
guy go i didn't even get arrested
if i was tack i probably would have said
to him hey just so you know
i understand that you probably been [ __ ]
on a lot people are shitty to each other
it's hard living downtown and whatever
your issues might be
i can be sympathetic but just so you
know if you had picked up my wallet
and said hey man here's your wallet i
probably would have broke you off
something
and now maybe somebody wouldn't have and
that would have been a chance he had to
take but
at some point how about we all just
start being nice to each other and just
see where that gets us
rather than stealing don't give me a
[ __ ] look my look is like you're
trying to
you're trying to take advantage of this
guy for your [ __ ] air force ones you
think batman's ever like oh my [ __ ]
unity got [ __ ] up but i should get
someone on the street
wait for it and put a lot out of suicide
squad how do you not know
in tax defense he offered you he offered
20 bucks man
in the heat of the moment you said no
i'm going with the morally right thing
people are trying to take your money but
that's
it you know what on the second thought
one's a payback the others
can i get seventy more how about this
you know what you know i didn't want all
new shoes i just wanted to clean
how about this you know what you be tack
i'll be you you could have also taken
this angle
okay off me the two i'm tack yeah offer
me the 20. thank you
thank you so much hey no big deal you
know what i mean oh cool can i give you
some give you like 20 bucks or something
dude honestly 40 be great
boom and i know i feel like that how
would i feel then if i'm taking the
guy's mind i don't know you think he'd
be carrying around
with you like a [ __ ] disease that's
from the town
is your favorite scene in the town where
he tells him i need you to come with me
we're going to hurt some people and you
can never ask me about it again
who's kyle we think yeah you [ __ ]
love that part
so yeah that that recently just happened
to me but i
i to me it was different taking his
money i just stopped some of you taking
his money but i would have taken a thank
you
also to be fair maybe in hindsight i
don't remember
when i realized my shoes were ruined it
might have been before it might have
been at but you know adrenaline's going
ruined well they're not ruined but you
know what i
like nice kicks i keep my shoes clean
yeah do you have a shoe cleaning day
not a day but just as needed he does it
every night he gets home no really
no simple green makes it last a while
okay i usually do that that's riveting
but we'll do it off here
straight straight simple green and a
toothbrush you want me to uh
do you want me to tell the story i
didn't get to yes absolutely yes because
you had one from last episode yes you
did not get to
well before nick youssef
he might ask you guys this and you can
lie if you want for people who listen
have either one of you had a three-way
no we've been honest about this
okay yeah i can't remember i um did you
ever feel like one might have happened
and it just didn't panic my long story
short was
went home with two girls from a bar we
all get in bed we're
kissing and then this one passes
completely passes out and she's
just dead weight next to us yeah the two
of us just you still
yeah if you're in the boat keep paddling
she was done
she was face down out of it yeah because
that probably would have gone that way
if she didn't
yeah yeah uh i've never had the answer
is no i've never had one
because i've failed at all of them i've
had three times in my life
where i could have and all of them i'm
the reason
it didn't happen did you turn down the
twenty dollar
like the same kind of vibe like you
turned it down yes you [ __ ] yourself
so they offered me twenty dollars and i
kept being like i mean i threw you i'd
be good
i'm in high school this is the first one
okay
i'm in high school when you're in high
school
i don't think you should get too much
credit for anything you achieve nor
should you get too much blame for
anything you fail at because
it just kind of all happens yeah you
know what i mean
like people look pro athletes and people
like nobody worked harder than that kid
in high school there's no wonder he's an
nfl quarterback like
he didn't have the forethought to be a
pro bowler i'm sorry maybe there are
rare people who do but really just at
the time they were just
they were doing the thing that their
parents dropped them off at every day
that's all it was
so i'm at this girl's house
uh we'll call her angela and
angela and i are kind of like making out
and stuff it's
it's like christmas break middle of the
day
everybody's at work remember those
windows of time oh yeah
when it was like this is hey we're we're
basically adults right now like you
could go to somebody's house in the
summer i spent an entire summer
going to hang out with this girl that
had a crush on
at her grandparents house while they
like
either lived somewhere else or were just
gone and her parents were like yeah you
can stay at
grandparents all day and nobody else was
there so then i would just go over there
and hang out with her and we would just
watch
the tim mcgraw don't take the girl video
while my hand was on her butt
i remember that song yeah just don't
take
the girl yeah but remember the [ __ ] you
could do for hours when you were a kid
yeah just hold a boob for like three
hours and you were like this is
riveting mm-hmm do you remember the
first move you ever touched
i think so you do do you remember the
first boob i'm talking on skin
yeah on skin i don't know that's a tough
call i do
stephanie armstrong katie weinbaug's
basement hand up the t-shirt
and then i hit her underwire and not on
purpose
and then oh no i went like right over
the boob and then i was like
i'm hand on boob right now and i just
sat there literally next week
i just sat there next to her are you on
the couch no
we're watching tv we're both facing
forward and i've just got hand on boob
and the next day she called me she's
like that isn't going to happen again
oh she put it down huh i think neither
one of us planned for she's trying to
petrify she's like
oh i mean she was i mean we were like
what i was 16 she was like seven
but like just joking
i know the joke was just too easy uh no
we were both i think we were both
into junior high maybe beginning high
school yeah so anyway
angela it's like christmas prank
and and yeah yeah
where her house is kind of making out
and then she's like hold on a sec
and she goes and makes a phone call and
then she comes back
and she says uh
you stay here for a while and i'm like
oh
okay and i'm thinking what are you like
16 yeah
you driving yet yeah is that how you got
there maybe i'm even
it was definitely in high school yeah
no i can't remember i might have been
dropped off i think about the days you
make both
can you guys still hear me yeah i can't
hear myself yeah there you go now i'm
here to buzzing all right
hopefully that can be edited you won't
hear that on there just in your head
so uh well i'm at her house whatever and
she's like
you want to stay here for a bit and i
was like i'm thinking to myself like
oh we don't want to like make out
anymore
and then she goes no my friend kelly's
gonna come over
and i go okay and then she's like
we're gonna have we'll have the three of
us could have some fun and i
jesus and i go
i gotta go home what yeah and she's like
what
and i said i got i gotta get out of here
i was so afraid i wanna smack you in
your face right yeah i was so afraid
and it's like middle of winter and she's
like that's the kind of thing you get
scared
doing you know what i mean it's like
it's you're scared do it if you're
afraid
it's like haunted house i would still go
through it in my head i was like
you're still getting in there in my well
to be fair until recently i wouldn't go
in haunted houses either
so i was five years old man haunted
mansion scared the [ __ ] of me i never
went to another one until i was like 20
something
so she's like what do you mean i go
i gotta i gotta go home and she's like
you said you you could hang out for i'm
like
no i think i don't wanna leave and so
then i just
out of fear of what was gonna happen
when they were both there
i left oh first three-way gone
fast forward i'm in college
guys and girls we're over at this girl's
house
and we're we're hanging out and
everybody's having fun drinking
we're playing that game you ever play
the game past the ice no
it's a stupid game it sounds like
something you play in wisconsin though
yeah what the [ __ ] is this in chicago uh
you start out with
you start out with um one cube of ice
and then you go like guy girl guy girl
guy girl and then you have to pass the
ice back and forth and whoever gets it
last
those two people have to like make out i
made out so many dudes by accident that
way
so then
we start playing we start playing truth
or dare
and i get there to show my penis
now drinking hanging out with each other
whatever the reason was you're like all
right hold on let me work it up a bit
that was the problem jayla yeah
it wasn't worked up at all it was worked
out it was worthwhile
oh yeah it was tucked in and then the
nerve set in and it
it it got more down so then they were
like damn you gotta and i go
no no i'm good and they were like damn
you were there to show your penis you
have to show it
and we're in we're theater majors so
everybody's just
way too dramatic way too like you have
to you have to
and i was like no i don't wanna well
everyone else by the way in the group is
being like
if this [ __ ] bucks the system then
every other dare can be backed out of
if you right if you step up and you be
the man and you do your dare
then that means anything else that comes
up right has to go down and you guys
know me i'll show your damn dick
you son of a [ __ ] well and you get that
turtle shell out you never know me do
you think
up until like before it was my turn do
you think i was forgiving of what people
did or didn't want to talk
i was like [ __ ] take that tit out
that's right right
so i was like no i don't wanna and i
i'm hoping that maybe as i argue it'll
get worked up
but it's not you know i'm like trying to
get blood in there
yeah just jumping around a little bit
you know
and i go uh i go i got i know i don't
want to do it they're like you then
you're not playing the game and i go
fine i don't want to play the game
i'm going to get water yes and i
i leave and i go into one of the girls
room and i'm
i'm hot i'm pissed i'm like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] truth today again making me show
my tiny dick
all sudden two girls debbie
and emily come into the room they're
like dan
come back out here and i go no [ __ ] you
guys [ __ ] this game
i'm gonna stay in this room until you
all leave and then i'll come out and
i'll leave i'm in debbie's room
and they're like dan come on here and
i'm like no [ __ ] this [ __ ] i don't want
to [ __ ] play your game they're like
what's the mat why
why don't why won't you show your dick
and i go
because it's too little and it's
embarrassing they go
what and i'm like it's just i don't have
a hard day i don't want to show my
little lip dick i love that you're like
listen i'll show a hard day i'm a grower
not a shower what do you want me to say
man i don't know if i'm either but i
definitely wanted to give it a shot
and i said i said no i'm embarrassed or
whatever and they're like
what if we help you and i'm like tell me
what
and they're like well we'll help you get
hard
and i go no and they're like
damn very supportive group damn man
i go dance they're like damn come on and
then they're like harassing me and
they're literally both
like grabbing my pants and i'm like get
away from me leave me alone
and they're like we will do whatever you
want us to do to get you hard and i'm
like no just forget it why don't you
guys go play your stupid [ __ ] game
and these two girls look at me and
they're like you don't want us
to arouse you and i go no
good lord hey man thanks for coming on
this might be your last episode
this is depressed i was more mad
but i was you were scared you were
scared still
then he was like oh they're gonna know
because they're gonna have their hand on
my tiny dick
about an hour later for no reason i got
a hard on and i was like look at it now
everybody was like put your [ __ ] away
[ __ ] yeah we're watching [ __ ]
father the bride right yeah everybody
needs a
pooper that's why we invited you
uh people are gonna hate me for messing
up that quote so then
um flash forward a couple years later
man i'm at a bar and there's these two
girls
and i'm talking to both of them we're in
l.a at this point nope we're in dekalb
illinois at a bar called fatties
and it's got like outdoor patio
everybody's playing cornhole bags called
bags playing bags and
having a good time it's just a summer
yup summertime
college bar in northern illinois
university great time
and there's a hotel next to the bar so
sometimes on weekends people just get a
couple of rooms nobody has to drive
and we're having a great time and i meet
these two girls that go to school there
i started talking to both of them
and i'm like oh what are you guys into
and all of a sudden
everything i say is hilarious
hands on the arms like i'm like man
i got to get another guy to come talk to
these girls
so that you know apparently you really
don't know how to play it
i'm not the best man oh man i would have
been shielding my back to anybody that
looked
remotely attracted behind me like let me
just get to it nope that would have been
too smart
so corey my buddy cory's i'm like corey
come over here and talk to these girls
and corey's like
i'm good man like on the exhale like
he can see what's going on and i'm like
oh i'm like girls come on
what do you guys go get corey to come
over here and then like shoot over there
i'm like give him a hug let's make cheer
him up and then she like give him a hug
and then i go suck his dick all right
but corey why don't you come back he's
like he's like i know dude seems to me
like those girls are pretty interested
in talking to you i'm like whatever and
later on i'm getting more drunk i'm like
give corey a kiss you know one of them
like gives corey a kiss on the cheek and
i'm like koi
these girls wanna hang out they seem
really interested in us and he's like
whatever you say dan so then the bar we
drink the whole time and it's just me
and these two girls
hanging out bar closes
and i can't find my cousin kenny and i'm
like i don't
i'm like girls you guys have a great
night i'm sorry i gotta find my cousin
ken and they're like
no we'll help you and i'm like
fine whatever i'm just going to the
hotel to find kenny and then it's corey
and our buddy brad who
who came up earlier that's who hopefully
bradford yes
we're there and uh they're like yeah
dude i think they're with
jeff remember jeff from that that was
mancation jeff the guy who
like went ape [ __ ] and yeah so
we're like looking around we're looking
at these girls follow me to the hotel
then they follow me through like four
different rooms of people and i keep
people like who are these two girls i'm
like i don't know girls so you don't
have to be here they're like no we're
happy to help
so then we find kenny i go kenny what's
your deal dude because
uh brad he he's not drunk he's good he's
driving us back do you ride with us he's
like no i'm just gonna stay here
i go all right fine and then we walk
back to the parking lot while our stuff
is and the girls are like
did you want to leave with us and i'm
like brad corey where are you guys going
they're like we're going back man and
i'm like
all right i guess i'm going to go with
my friends
and the girls go they're a little
looking at me they're like
it's two in the morning we're asking you
to come back to
our house i'm like yeah i know but my
friends aren't they don't want to go
and then she goes god we're asking you
to come back to our house with us
can i go i go no i get it but nobody
else wants to go
and one girl goes my god and walks away
goes to the car right second girl is
still standing she's like you really
don't want to leave
with me i go now and she goes
do you want to see my boobs i mean how
much heavier can this girl lay it on
seriously and i go
yeah of course i want to see your boobs
and she's like okay
so she shows them and i go those are
great
staying in this gravel parking lot in
dekalb illinois
those are great she's like thanks
you sure you don't want to come with us
and i go
no i'm pregnant what a [ __ ] i can't
even jail
i can't go any further i don't want to
hear anything i don't want to hear
anything else out of your mouth
i go brad and corey are being dicks
she's like i don't give a [ __ ] about
brad and cory how about tina and jesse
that's what i call my titty
get the [ __ ] in the car you dummy she
goes
okay i guess i'll never see you again
and guys i swear hand to god
she says i guess i'll never see you
again and i look her in the eye and i go
no
i'll find you on my sleeve oh my god
listen let me be straight up i get it
the first time in high school i get it
you were scared you were young i had
moments that like things were happening
and i like blocked because i was a
little nervous yeah the college one okay
you didn't want to show your your
johnson i get it it's real tiny i've
heard from other people too it's tiny
that i understand this now is the
dumbest thing i've ever heard
this girl has her breasts out at you in
the parking lot
and with a friend i mean just the
dumbest thing
she goes what and then her friend goes
let's go
they spent their whole night on you i
know
i still haven't first of all there is no
best part of this story he still hasn't
had a friend request on facebook myspace
[ __ ]
whatever at this point i still had not
realized
what had happened like what was wait you
still didn't know at that point you were
gay i'm like what
that's what matters if i'm gay dude it
doesn't matter uh
i guess that would break i'm not
interested in spending time with two
women at once
so i go i go
like even when she showed me her boobs i
was like this girl's awesome
and then that's like as far as it went
she must have been like
we just met the dumbest [ __ ] dude in
the world so she
i go i'll find you on my space and she
looks at me and like what
and then she just leaves she says oh
okay
i walked to the car cory and brad are
still standing there both smoking
cigarettes
and i go you guys ruined the night
you're the dumbest [ __ ] i've
ever known ever i go
i go what guys you ruined it i go corey
i got that girl she was giving you a hug
and kisses they wanted to hang out with
you all night
brad where you weren't even around dude
those girls would have hung out with us
all night and they're like you are a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then they both replay
back to me the night and i feel like
bruce willis in the sixth sense
like i'm seeing everything but like
their hands are on me one of them's got
their armor and they're like let's take
a picture together
they follow me to a hotel for no reason
that no one that we're not staying at
help me find my cousin boobs in a
parking lot and it just all
and then i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] and they
just
spent even to this day they're like
you're the dumbest person we've ever
ever you're officially just took that
tight on my what life too
dumbest person i've ever met right
i'd rather be the dumb guy than the guy
who's always trying to get one of those
but you weren't you weren't traveling
they came in your lap
i know i'd had no clue i mean literally
i had
titties in your face in a parking lot
that's four threesome stories he turned
down
today that's unbelievable because of the
the wallet guy yeah the wall guy and the
homeless chick
could add those too
man and then on the last episode the two
guys in the bathroom marshall fields
could have had those guys could have had
them
definitely that's why gentlemen
unbelievable dude i can't even i was at
a um
at a bar one night my buddy jim and i
were at this bar we were actually at uh
mexicali
the guac bar um uh that's a good spot we
meet these two girls
we see them at the bar and we're like i
was just gonna go talk to them you know
probably nothing's gonna happen but
we'll see what we start making
uh you know plenty of progress and then
they're like hey we live
just around the corner you know it's
last call you guys want to come back to
our place we're like yes we didn't
daniel vancouver we're like a hundred
percent
so we get out back and their car is
parked like
right here and then i'm just i'm not i'm
not 20 feet away
yeah and jim's chit-chatting them up and
everything i go let me go get the car
i'll pull it around as i
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened it
was it couldn't have been more than like
15 seconds
i pull up and as i'm pulling up i see
the one girl coming at me like
mega aggressive and she's giving her
titties out
she did she had that's aggressive she
had pepper spray out that's she really
yeah that's aggressive
jesus this is the other side of the coin
this [ __ ] was in some kinky [ __ ] man
we were just there i i turned my back
just to walk to the car i get in
i loop around and they're all still
standing there
the other girl and here are fine she
just comes over aggressive and she goes
i swear and i'm rolling my window up
because it's some i'm like trying to get
my one i'm like jesus christ like what
the [ __ ] is
and he starts getting the pastor's side
she's like yeah i [ __ ] i'll pepper
spray you i swear to god i'll pepper
spray you and i'm like i just want to
get the car i look at him and i go
what the [ __ ] just happened and he just
dead serious he's like
i have no idea and and that was it they
were really he didn't ask for three ways
he didn't ask no it just turned yeah
because the other girl was okay and then
that one just turned out of nowhere like
i don't know if all of a sudden she
realized we're actually coming and she's
not down for it right maybe her friend
was or something i don't know what was
going on but
she's straight up trying to i'll be 100
honest i'll be i'll be
honest i don't know i don't know
i i am worried about if i was in a
three-way i don't
i don't think really are you being
honest about it we all know you eating
about it because i just all right it's
too much for you we get it i've been
sitting here
thinking about worrying about making
like two women happy at once
no i feel like they would have to both
be not doing a lot of the work
because i it's really hard i i want to
they were your opportunities were them
telling you
let us take care of you let us get you
hard
come back with us us it wasn't you
uh you know you didn't hang it off them
not only that you got the two of them
there
you can go you can go a couple rounds
yeah you know what i mean you don't need
to just have
to be a one-time shot man are you
kidding me i gotta get out here i gotta
go get on my space i've been thinking
back i'm like have i ever
i've never been in that situation never
attended for a long time you never had a
snare you're like man this could go
if i didn't have to worry i'm actually
thinking about one time that i had i was
gonna hook up with this girl and her
friend came with us but i'm thinking
there was never one point where the
other girl was like hey
let me get involved i just never that
never no it's my whole life
if there's been two women and i've been
attracted to them and in a room with
them
i'm hoping that that's going to happen i
feel like i would fail
hoping that that's going to happen i'm
like huh i wonder if these two would
want to
remember that seinfeld where where jerry
needs to get out of dating the girl
he's dating this chick and he can't
stand she doesn't think he's funny and
everything like that but the roommate is
super hot and thinks he's hilarious
and he's like how do i yeah how do i
date the other one and george is like
you ask her for a three-way
she goes he goes the girl you're dating
she's going to be so turned off boy
she's going to be out but the other
friend is going to be like
oh that's kind of flatter go for it
remember and then
george goes so what happened and jerry's
like she's into it
and he's like what he goes yeah and he
goes what do you do he's like hold on no
he goes
what what do you mean he goes i'm not a
i'm not an orgy kind of guy
or i don't have oils because i need to
get oils
curtains oh
well we are there daniel van we are we
are there
wow that is blue
crashing halt at the end 20 minutes
oh man they're gonna kill you rightfully
so
that's okay this one guy a guy tried to
give me a million dollars and i said i
know you need it
you've turned down a lot you turned down
the money that the attack wanted to give
you and then you wanted [ __ ] in that and
then you turned down the ass
thank you so much for being here again
man this has been a lot of fun as always
this is the fastest it's ever gone so
that probably says something about the
quality of the show like you said but
well in your eyes yeah in your eyes
thank you please i love you guys and i
love your fans i can't wait to people
say hi to brad if you want to make fun
of me for the
things i've done that's you went out the
first and let them know where they can
find you to make fun of you on social
media
daniel van kirk that's on the instagram
it's on the twitter the myspace is still
out there
i talked about that on the other episode
uh i think it's just daniel van kirk on
facebook
and then you can look for hindsight
every thursday on itunes as well as
scarborough county
every tuesday with the what every
tuesday
ever with the scholar brothers and yeah
i'm just doing stuff around man and i've
been doing a lot of stand up so i'd love
for people to come out to those shows
that's it
that's great to have you on buddy i
always love seeing you love hanging out
with you
feel the same um as always
jlarsoncomedy.com j larson comedy on
facebook twitter instagram and pinterest
ryan sickler on all social media ryan
sickler.com we'll talk to you all
next tuesday